okay so we've got a lot of properties
I've got so much and I just need to
refine so everything I was told about
some of them I've got some properties
that I bought nine ten years ago they've
gone up in value and I could just do
movie formats and pull money out other
ones we've just bought for cash some of
them you know that lease option
agreements
yeah and some does that doesn't matter
so some of them I bought I bought them
on a lease option agreement basis like
again five six seven years ago but now
I'm bonding cash
heavily below market value I know could
we thought I could be financed and
potentially but I'll go through the
whole lot yeah but luckily the ones that
have bought on lease option agreement so
I've just bought mm-hmm they need a
little bit of refurb because I'm not
directed to them in seven years Leaguers
are we verb them yeah it's been five 10
grand on them but then when I get the
refinance bit easier
I've also spoke to stand walking about
trying to hide it why not Heidi so I've
just bought sat load of properties but
he's trying to keep them twice at the
new prices on land registry right by a
little bit the tension life so I don't
think you need to run things you don't
have to know because if they go and they
see that I bought it for 80 grand
but and I'm saying it's worth looking
six day then we like that's weird what
about Freight man so I'm going to try
yeah
kanya all your online registry sam says
you used to build it a bit easier and
it's a bit trickier yeah some of you
were going to tell me but my
understanding is you don't it's not
mandatory that you should put the
purchase price on there yeah which yeah
so anyways what means then is when
Hollywood does his homework because it's
a she
yes that's powering Zoopla yeah then
what you're saying well the average
price - yeah people typing these things
yeah having four like so
yeah cos something that you that valuers
made it so that you do have to you do
have to say right in me what videos I
see but I think there's ways around it
and also you can also you can sometimes
say look we bought it for this price
because it was from a lease option
agreement or whatever but put these
value rather than the twice pay so yeah
yeah I think we've had a number of
scenarios know where people are buying
property under market value mm-hmm
they want to borrow this is the value
yeah however from the valuations are
happening it's coming on the purchase
price and the valuations are coming in
but actually come in at the purchase
price or the value he's doing their
due-diligence
yeah because there is an argument that
also says the purchase price piece of
the value yeah so it's but with the
lease option agreement this difference
so it is a bit of a wine I think it's
the lazy way to value like we do if we
can post it we're we're impossible
okay speak to sympathetic lender
somebody that's it as you mentioned sort
of you like that sort of thing yeah
option to do that yeah you have
emergency the value at see any problem
that's somebody might say yes because
we've out in the pack but we've got a
value down value it but then we've got a
different value would go is that not
normal you can be because it is depends
on the comparables there is no yes there
are some metrics I suppose but it's
within parameters usually you tend not
to find value as being massively active
when another less this is significant
property yeah this was this was a block
of flats and they and someone valued it
so maybe a value about it as a HMO even
though there's a block of flats very
good and then we got another values as a
fundamental difference tearing yeah what
drop the value if they both came back
there's a hate you more than you'd
expect them to be largely the same yeah
suspect yeah but you can you know you've
got palettes this kind of language with
a letter panel of values River Linda mmm
happy with one you can always request
another it just means how am i qualified
you go down the line before yeah so this
is a list of all the properties that we
that we're looking to refinance yeah a
lot of them we've just bought the cash
yeah
also as well sure you said that we get
to wait six months which isn't as it
happens it's not really an issue for if
you wait six months but wait six months
yeah but I thought that there was some
the six month Florida Colombian scrapped
why some lenders like can't be lines for
instance I thought they didn't make you
wait six months anymore they don't
you've done illumise you've added value
to the property so something does don't
have it you actually like the camera
lights also they will do so same day
mortgage so either to breach or
something and you one of you know you
can water straight away okay what the
rule is with that is they will if you've
bought it today if you haven't done any
improvements to the property yeah it
would be the purchase price so how will
it work they move some of the lease
option agreement because honestly some
of these properties like for instance
okay Marybel brothers yeah if you can
see that one yeah that one
the others are selling in the street
exactly the same for about one between
118 200 I think 185 is a conservative
estimate evaluation mmm
I just bought it last month for a
hundred and one okay so is it massively
reduced yeah that was because it was a
lease option agreement and I agreed to
buy it like seven years ago I've bought
it for cash yeah and I want to refinance
the house was one that I bought and I
put in a family members name and the
agreement was that after whenever I
wanted to I could buy it the price of
the mortgage right okay and that was
actually more than seven years I think
it was about it was two thousand nine
ten years ten years ago that was and and
and now I'm like alright then I'll
transfer it over to my name so I've now
bought the property off my family member
for the price of the mortgage but really
it's kinda like in my mind it was always
my property yeah because they they're
doing reason they put in their name was
because at the time I was too young to
get more okay yeah and I think what we
these are slightly different on the
basis that I think each one of these
cases we need to discuss specifically
with the lender yeah to get them you
know I can just cite what their rules
are yeah all your cards on the table
okay look I bought it for this price
they reason about it for this price was
because yeah
XYZ I now want to refinance it and do
that way yeah and they can understand
very risk in that that's how they try to
understand really is if something should
happen and you couldn't afford to repay
for whatever reason and they went to the
open market with it give them the way
that it's been purchased if that could
be detrimental to the value of the
profits that we would go through this
just like this commercial budget that we
buy in the core point oh yeah billion
yeah what would that make you reckon
would you would you like to do that kind
of thing yes so we do commercial plans
yeah that for that let's pick up some
residential you are bridging hence our
involvement in the manor house yeah
I'm commercial property because they
just can't cope with that with what we
because also also what you mention this
a lot of people ask me not a snaffle for
yeah but we get asked a lot I mean I
broke you'd recommend hmm and every
broker we've ever recommend it always
ends up getting so overwhelmed with work
they can't deal with it come on yeah
well obvious like no no was like untrue
that happen with even the new just only
yeah I mean this no I appreciate things
like time sometimes things like time
that's cool but we do something by a
certain time frame and then go yeah
because then it's like if you say look
this is gonna take a little while Oh
back on Monday and then Tuesday were
like that's when ami gets ticked off I
don't like sighs I appreciate things
take time but I'll it's an expectation
for Samuel and other people and things
like that saying I'll have information
to you by Friday cuz that's what my
mortgage brokers said and then they I
don't hear anything and then I'm being
chased by Samuel doesn't know why it
hasn't happened solicitors don't know
why it's happening it's what's going on
with you say yeah that's what you'll
find is and this does happen that got
kissed
they're just prime example this at the
moment swear by the lender will tell you
a lot this by you tomorrow
they're wicked by tomorrow they're you
don't deliver to you by tomorrow yeah
then dominar I can go and then everybody
well we want to do is we want everyone
at least in our team to do what they say
won't miss I you know so that way like
because when we've got a solicitor
mortgage broker builders this that all
these different people in the palutena
agents people saying they're gonna go
and view a property for always you bring
the team at least as far as we can
control it if everyone just just what
the side when inside they're going to do
it that's a big thing with the you
raised it's like a four hundred thousand
didn't really and only just it was too
bad than that was it no I was more than
you would expect but the time for 10
days so yeah have you big stuff in the
pattern just on Wow
Abby just comes to me couple songs a
week
with a bunch of stuff I need to sign
yeah and then a very brief look at home
just to check that I'm not signing my
net worth over to either you or anything
like that you know check it out so I
mean that's kind of odd isn't it yeah
but what are we thinking about this well
so we've got this there's two questions
here really one is the refinance at the
portfolio yeah I think we're we need to
get complete steer from is how a tree
would keep the valuation given that
there's lease options and so on
associated to it so I think we need
steel and that is what we don't want to
do is to get to the process where we
we'd get to evaluate what do you think
what do you think that thing if we said
to them like for instance this marybelle
Road which I'm buying four hundred more
it's clearly a lot more than that do you
can then accept that and just value
about the actual value what you think it
will be downloaded somewhat because of
the circumstances bear in mind on net
worth individual I've got I said I mean
I think that supports the mortgage
application full-stop
yeah the new loan to value would be
driven obviously by the value yeah so
outside of your net worth that will
still be driven by what the property
valuation so it was still come down to
the same question I think ultimately
it's a difficult one because really
realistically you in theory bought it
seven years ago
yes changed ownership but you have the
arrangement that you had yeah ten years
there were certain lenders which are
very quickly rewritten and will not sway
outside of that but they've priced
accordingly so they would be cheap there
are other lenders that take a more
commercial view on these things yeah and
we can have a conversation with the
director again directors without sort of
trying to run that conversation with two
lemmas I can think of off the top of my
head that we would just have a
conversation
explain what we're doing get them
comfortable once we know that that's the
case it'd be good if there well we will
just keep feeding them the work I
understand it yeah
you know all of your lease agreement
yeah agreements we can just vote well
here's another one there's another one
yeah as long as we can communicate what
that is that we're trying to do to the
lender let me submit an application I
don't even mean telling who we're
working with yeah I have this now are
you oh yeah okay we haven't got we
haven't got Milford Avenue on here oh it
is is so this property can you see 2010
like never lovin it yeah this property
bargain 10 these the values are all
based on my research looking at what
sold so you know their lenders may just
may disagree sometimes I've been a bit
conservative in my opinion so I bought
it for 68 it's now worth 110 yeah and
now I just want to refinance that okay
long like overall big picture what I
want is I want to be able to just pull
out as much as I can from all this and
then reinvest all of this is on capital
interest repayments is it it's all
interesting yeah okay okay so one thing
that the consider then is what your long
between exit strategies we are lending
potentially eighty percent loan to
values five select values and come 20
years expiry mm-hmm they're good all the
money back
yeah so we have to just understand I'm
probably give thought to what is the
exit and so you probably if you can wear
appropriate puts someone to cap an
interest someone to interest only just
to manage that so you are creating it
yeah although I'll be surprised if you
don't go up ah yes it depends I sent
your
Midlands towards the North Mill you're
buying where we are seeing more property
appreciation value that's more staffing
and I'm going
probably from the opposite weight a
little bit of loneliness so you know we
train a little somebody trying to do
what you get capital out yeah I think we
need to have one ion okay where where is
the optimum size and how do we then
start repaying some of this or is it
simply paste with our bye bye bye bye
bye and I'll sell a lot and that's my
edge astrology if that's the case that
would be yeah because unless it goes
down in value and then you're in
negative equity if it comes to the end
of the mortgage and you can't pay it off
your other refinance and extend it again
because I'm a young guy could probably
do that or just sell it yeah no
absolutely not I mean I think there is
some some thought to be given to exit
cool so yeah so I think my plan is to
disable and reinvest it exit strategy is
number one I've got a really high cash
flow business and I've always got cash
in the bank yeah number two is last
resort I can always sell yeah the
properties but I personally don't think
after 20 years these properties
especially in the areas that they're in
I'd be very surprised they've gone up
because you know we always see a
recession followed by an expansion
followed by recession probably these are
overall going of it but of course you
can never put your life on it
yeah I'm I'm always gonna take the
coarsest answers yeah and that's your
husband what people to plan you to do is
live exactly so you know I'll always
take a cautious we want to get again we
probably will see some yeah okay so what
do you need from me then to make this
happen
well I've got application forms and the
like so basically once I've got one
application form filling yeah because of
the same over and over depending on
which company I was in yes that was over
to you the commercial mortgage is
slightly different because that is
commercial borrowing
forms over so we'll do that as well
basically once a capture or Viktor we
can go in
yeah patient's off do you know that well
the backstory is on all the houses and
why I bought so cheap would that be
helpful yeah who cooks they'll be great
all right that's no problem I just give
you the story on anything I feel is
relevant anything if I'm boring just
tell me and I'll shut up
but maybe straight that's an interesting
property that because that property that
property I didn't I found out that the
house was owned by company it's really
good house ain't you know more Hampton
it was owned in a company so instead of
buying the house I bought the company
okay and I did to avoid playing three
percents Dungy so yeah so I ended up
anything half a percent peanuts
so that is currently that property is
owned by finger-post Homes limited I
will explain just why when you come here
yeah so I don't know did I buy that
wrong do 18 Graham because I'm never
buying that company for 36 front right
because I just bought the company and I
bought the company for thee so the price
that I was gonna buy the house for I
just worked out hand who's gonna be in
the glass pocket and then just gaining
that and have to come back and I'm
pretty sure I just took over the
existing mortgage is on entity no on you
yeah yeah so the company or was the
money not yeah so that was a really
interesting more than same stamp duty so
that's that one and that was um I bought
that I gave reasonably recent yeah 15
and 16 Tudor so those those departments
Bournemouth bottling cash yeah really
straightforward I bought on a good price
but nothing incredible if they get down
value to the price I bought them for
that isn't even down values because to
be honest I wore them for about maliki
battle yes so if the mortgage comes up
to 68 in 67 on those turf that's fine by
me right okay I'll probably go into 75
because I think that they're worth
but they'll probably get down value and
I'll totally accept that yeah now though
I've told you the story on that
Maribel's also HMO us it's hmm it's
unlicensed there's just four people in
them and they're playing gay rent of
1400 pounds a month and they've been
playing that forever yeah I can prove
that with all the ice the TZ stuff if
you need me to purse your roads that
property is interesting I agreed to buy
that property for 89 thousand pound yeah
absolutely forever ago almost ten years
okay so it's it was actually an
unwritten lease option agreement I
didn't know what I was doing because I
was young so there's a lease option
agreement but we didn't have a proper
solicitor in place right so I just have
to hold my wife and cross my fingers
that he would only lose word right okay
okay and he did so I bought that for
eight nine grounds all I think that
property's worth oh it's definitely
weather well this way here so
interesting mark that properties went
now for 1,800 per month so I'm Mike
yelling so don't know you oh no ether
but get commercial valuation on it oh
yeah I think it's an HMO on sweets
really nice getting a team to Panama so
I don't know every month that's the
foliage of always interesting fully
licensed yeah so I don't know whether
that luck with I don't know quick you
get commercial valuation on that I think
because of the red ball that will
inflate the valuation tenants beautiful
it's in good condition and it's getting
18 it's understanding whether the lender
want it has a vacant possession or with
my only be other than a 140 other time
but I think I'll pop one six five but
I'll leave that one with yeah yeah sure
clean why that was an I was an
out-and-out lease option agreement
mm-hm I agreed to buy for eighty one
thousand seven years ago was he seven
years or was he fine I can't remember
but a long time ago it's gone up
considering value the guide tried to
pull out last month they said no please
Freight warned it's worth at least
13 now but I just said speak to the
solicitor that and obviously I had the
option to buy for 81 yeah I didn't screw
me over because at the time I took the
property on I said to him you're mad
selling it yeah keep it yourself why
don't you rent it out yourself I tried
to persuade it but he wasn't havin a
lease option then I made another
solicitor he was legally represented he
knew what he was doing so he then just
went fine fair enough and he sold it to
me to for 81 and then I just bought him
a nice gift
I also overpaid by mistake by 321 pounds
and then he messaged me he goes I've
just had a check them through to 300
pounds you hope you've overpaid me
how'd you ought to get the money back I
swear and I said just keep it yeah you
know we're on good terms but that
property is worth at least 110 I think
about 113 and that's a lease option
agreement because there's under standing
in the street for 120 yeah so it's so
obviously is worth more what do you what
do you think they'll do you think
they'll be good with that again I think
it's understanding the there's one
lender in particular that I can talk to
the underwriters who are more
commercially minded done some others
maybe yeah
and it's them understanding the lease
option agreement yeah and then while I
was going to it once they are happy with
it it's making sure that the value right
yeah
but such as couldn't give us one another
we want yeah sure
so getting the lender you have these one
thing probably were to come back with a
number we're after is something entirely
different
no I understand that walls worth road I
think these ones are actually we need a
medium yeah we haven't there those all
going through one two three four five so
the six properties yeah included some of
the bigger ones like Trent Business
Center which are going through but we
just need a straightforward mortgage and
so they're easy peasy we've trimmed
businesses well I have spoke to keeps a
little bit have been conversations about
that because your commercial
you're relying on the commercial income
recently yeah that services a little
significantly better
that's a really good value Doug yeah I'm
a certain you get children 10k Grameen
well we're getting to 10 K parameter and
we've agreed to buy it 1.4 million yeah
so I think we've got good deal what do
you think yeah I think that the value up
what exploiting what like about four
hundred thousand
yes about 350 350 that's not an issue
for 350 M because they don't have much
with them because look at making well
children 10 K it's serviceable owned by
300 percent so that's good and also as
far away from my house okay loschen
Street yeah that one we're buying in
cash
no we just bought that one that one went
through last week yeah for sixty four
thousand pounds mmm-hmm that needs about
10 grams pendant on it okay yeah once
I've spent that money on it the others
at the moment are selling the street for
about 90 grand
okay so I was hoping to be able to
refinance that wire all almost in one
month with the plan yeah let's fall into
that camera lights description which is
there has been works
yeah what I would say is I'm sure you do
keep the evidence the quotes and the
works of you know baking so that we can
shut up to the more enemies yeah and
there's many times we've had value is
being met with the clients yeah and they
give me a spiel and what else is going
on because yeah sometimes ever stuff oh
yeah well don't you talk about that over
the time you're going to tip for us with
the particular I don't know everything
is different and every value was
different all right exactly but that's
cool so that's that property which I'm
hoping about Paul I'm only happens to
wake up done corporation Street by you
still bought yeah cool no if it hadn't
have told you about yes that's the one
which we did I've just got a lot of
equity in it what are we finance air so
silly bridge we don't need anything done
to that the moment mmm mine won't
nothing
I don't see you rivers for two halves
when that's finished thinking that
potentially said it's really important
yeah yeah they asked me whether it's
nice to come over sometime see it
there's everything those deputies not
weird yeah yeah everything that could go
wrong with the building pretty much yeah
that's going really well that the
project's coming on really well good so
yeah I think you know all in all
reasonably straight forwards well I once
ever once just want to the lenders we
can also see I can also then once we
understand the lenders we know that our
values are you know anything about the
value but isn't ask them how they would
view the property
so before we start pressing all the
buttons react need to have those
conversations to understand however it's
nice I'm happy to the my tokus to
everything if kids have to decide to us
or we can give you a hundred percent
wants or something crazy and fine but on
a mom but but German speaking of having
future do the having good under percent
fines but you need to offer an
additional security so you in effect
build equity into it which is kind of
adapted for your energy properties that
you owned outright and your integrity
and your better to then type of charge
on those properties yeah but then you
can't refinance those properties so it's
counterproductive for you if you go for
full as any come only to one upon us
it's out of it but you want a hundred
percent lose your cash that's right as
useful some people who don't have the
cash flow to a table but have assets we
can then say well actually we'll take
another - it wasn't added to offer our
security yeah okay so what what are the
next steps then and how long do you
think all this will take obviously it's
a process it's a journey or something
that's in one and agree with yeah more
so we get you an agreement in principle
yeah
by this solicitous yeah is there a
deadline to complete to us there's not a
dead mom but they don't buy them in rush
everyone sir
yes yeah well fine what we've got is I
think I've sent their forms over for
that one which is outpatient robbery
edge or if you can complete them and
just pin them back
I think we find that we can get agree
with the principle yes assuming they
don't have too many questions and so on
and so forth so we could certainly
engage with them I can engage myself
going back home in a car to be honest
what really decides this audience a key
idea is yes we can get mortgage on it
everything's all good here's a mortgage
brokers details yeah and then thank you
you can just better comfort really to
give to the vendor but things are
progressing yeah
which one are you most excited about the
business centers whirring when I do
Microsoft commercial yeah and so what
you did with yeah those two are probably
the one there's a jump over to me but I
do think people probably do a bit of a
job on the portfolio frontier available
properties yeah do you reckon yeah
because yeah because they're all in my
own personal my mama yeah
what did you say for the commentary
property Robeson Road was this Vida home
loans and outstanding more beautiful but
its marks on how was that and if you're
already public through the process
six properties I'm already doing okay so
we're basically ready to complete pretty
much on the nice yes am i right - not
interested for others I mean for playing
strategy we happy with what I said about
accessorizing oh you need to run the
numbers basically but if you're in a
variable rate mortgage also would you
recommend fixing these interest rates
for as long as possible because
obviously they're pretty low right now
on that yeah I think that come down to
two factors what is the fixed rate
versus a variable rate
yeah difference margin is there are we
are we playing to see interest rates go
up dr. Bridget we've seen some small
marginal increases now very small
business and you know simple tiny just
tweaking them up yeah - I'll do example
this one of stuff yeah again you know I
noticed you've got a few on here - like
fours and yeah well that's not good some
of these I believe yeah - and with fixed
you've got a five and a half percent
very well but these really expensive
ones they're variable so I need to I'm
not saying you can play very good well
they're so expensive
it's usually the target Julie the lender
but they're not lend was there for a
reason
five I mean that may be straight meteor
that changed that way I was just you can
do simple things that's just speak to
kind alliance that might just be Anna
standard variable rate yeah that might
not be any product anymore
I'm just going to stand it very clear in
them and get a Tennessee three or four
percent yeah it's very good phone call
so he's doing necessarily need to
refinance that just to speak to clients
you said look I'm happy about this can
we sort that out because I'm really
gonna give up and then the same with
Sonny which you don't necessarily need
to disturb it but speak to paragon that
maybe you see I'm happy with this 2.49
on my wall yeah I mean I I'm paying
eighty seven pound a month on that and
that's fixed but also Millfield Avenue
I'm saying 4.49 that's quite expensive
yeah a fixed street
rebuilding society it's up there but
again if that's a five year fixed for
nuts
yeah stablished standard is this it's
very really probably looking at more
closer to the three plates force maybe
three effectual cinema numbers so you
know 4.49 fix or five uses no space only
get about three percent yeah we're like
me likely to get a better deal with the
portfolio because i'm doing loads at
once or not that's been done a lot about
new supported trying to pull out yeah so
if you think I'll have to put it always
in my mind I was thinking of leaving 25
percent here I think that's sensible
you start to squeeze as much okay let's
go
yeah and you start to have that
volatility so it does have two markets
you've got left room for error
I think 24 percent in each standard yes
yes is the way so how we would look at
this one is you know we wouldn't
necessarily go for rate first on this we
would look for the lender that would do
this type of borrowing on this i relent
in my circumstances yeah once you
identify the lenders if there's more
than one then we will look at pricing
and then we don't go for the cheapest
yeah and then we got a look at their
panel of values which other than see a
retreat of properties yeah and that's
probably order of yeah and hope for the
times how I don't know we don't know for
sure but would you imagine a couple of
months maybe we should be able to get
the money out well refinancing of
existing properties is far quick and
abiding so you're looking at six six
weeks yeah face to face implants yeah
let's move so much you know there's over
the five not going to be lost
yeah because there's a lot sorted and
thank you so much I like it now
[Music]
Thanks let's go down okay
what's it did you be pleased to anything
no just need you to twerk it just don't
really deal with things yeah just the
when when when we expected to complaints
like the plans to look now that would be
ready first we can make balls yeah and
we're complete as you think we were too
after that what we do is we exchange
yeah yeah I'm just trying this what is
the other clients gonna be cheap enough
it's such a good one is that gonna make
one point to Miller
yeah sounds like a for you very well
yeah hasn't it busy as ever at least for
now
Oh what do you have to isolate
Litchfield would recall of have some
dinner sounds good yeah alright that's
cool it's cool thanks so much where
these change message our baby will get
in the door I love it alright thanks so
much thank you
Cheers
oh you're trouble it's in the cloud you
know that thing where just Chuck stuff
up Nick floats around it's landing on
your desk
all right go for Trevor so what you
thinking